Bélgica es el país de los
mejillones con patatas fritas,
las cervezas artesanales y uno de los mejores
chocolates del mundo. Sin embargo amigos,
en unos años puede que Bélgica sea más conocida
por ser el narcoestado de la Unión Europea.
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado bien.
Su puerto marítimo más importante, el de Amberes,
se ha convertido en la mayor puerta de entrada de
narcóticos ilegales en Europa. Las mafias se
están haciendo de oro traficando sustancias
como la cocaína y la metanfetamina. Y para
mantener este business están dispuestas a todo.
Así que en VisualPolitik nos
hemos hecho varias preguntas:
¿Cómo ha llegado Bélgica a convertirse en algo así
como el sueño europeo de Pablo Escobar? ¿Cómo está
afectando todo esto a la vida corriente de los
ciudadanos belgas? Y lo que es más importante:
¿Qué se está haciendo para combatirlo?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a
estas preguntas. Pero antes, antes
vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
T1
(AMBERES, EL HUB EUROPEO DEL NARCO)
Ubicado en el corazón de Europa, el de Amberes
es un puerto atípico porque no está en la costa
sino 80 kilómetros tierra adentro, al
comienzo del estuario del río Escalda.
Y de hecho, esta peculiaridad es
precisamente la que favorece que
el puerto de Amberes sea el segundo con mayor
tráfico de mercancías del continente europeo.
(El Puerto de Amberes cuenta con
50 kilómetros de muelles que están
conectados con el interior del continente
europeo por ferrocarril, carretera,
vías fluviales y canales. En estos muelles se
descargan cada año 11 millones de contenedores.
En total más de 235 millones de toneladas
de mercancias entran anualmente en el viejo
continente utilizando este puerto,
el doble que hace apenas 20 años.)
¡11 millones de contenedores! En una
cuenta rápida, estamos hablando de
más de 30.000 contenedores cada día. Y
pensad que el comercio marítimo ofrece
al narcotráfico las mismas ventajas
que a cualquier otra industria: con los
contenedores se transportan altos volúmenes
de mercancía a un coste relativamente bajo.
Como podéis imaginar, controlar lo que llega en
cada uno de estos contenedores es prácticamente
una misión imposible para los 700 agentes
de aduanas que tiene el puerto de Amberes.
Porque las cifras del Puerto son
completamente abrumadoras. Estos
700 agentes tienen que supervisar a
60.000 trabajadores entre estibadores,
operadores de grúas y el resto de
profesionales del puerto. Y claro,
como podéis imaginar, en cestos tan
grandes siempre hay manzanas podridas.
(El caso es que la corrupción ha penetrado en
el puerto Amberes durante los últimos años.
Las mafias han logrado infiltrar a topos como
trabajadores del Puerto. De esta forma tienen
la capacidad de indagar quién puede ser, llegado
el caso, más susceptible de aceptar un soborno.
Habitualmente hablamos de mucho dinero,
varios miles de euros, por trabajos tan
sencillos como facilitar algo de información. Y si
el trabajador en cuestión no acepta ser comprado,
las mafias siempre pueden tratar de intimidarlo
con amenazas. Por eso se cree que la cantidad de
personas que trabajan para las organizaciones
criminales en el puerto es cada vez mayor.)
A través de sus túneles con grandes escáneres,
el Puerto de Amberes actualmente supervisa
1 de cada 200 contenedores. Así que podéis
imaginaros hasta qué punto tener información
sobre el día a día en el Puerto puede
llegar a ser importante. Los agentes de
aduanas buscan artículos de contrabando,
productos falsificados y, sobre todo,
los polvos blancos procedentes de América Latina.
Y por supuesto no estoy hablando del azúcar ni
tampoco de la sal. La coca se ha convertido en una
de las reinas de la fiesta del puerto de Amberes.
Precisamente por eso, en el punto de mira de
los equipos de aduanas se sitúa de forma muy
especial el comercio con Sudamérica. Los
narcotraficantes aprovechan los envíos de
fruta fresca como las bananas y las piñas para
esconder su particular mercancía en su interior.
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis. Y muchos os
preguntaréis, pero ¿por qué en la fruta fresca?
Bueno, si lo pensáis se trata de una de las
principales exportaciones de Sudamérica a Europa,
por tanto no debería ser un cargamento que a
priori pusiera sobre alerta a la aduana. Otro
detalle muy importante es que estamos hablando
de productos perecederos, lo que hace que las
prisas para que se distribuyan rápidamente por los
mercados sean mucho mayores. Además, un contenedor
de fruta no deja de ser uno más entre los miles
que circulan cada día por Amberes, así que las
posibilidades de ocultar los narcóticos son
enormes y el riesgo de ser detectado es mínimo.
(El modelo de negocio de las mafias es
enviar masivamente tantos contenedores
cargados con estupefacientes como sea posible.
Son conscientes de que en las aduanas pueden
permitirse una pérdida de entre un 10 y
un 20% de su carga. Una pérdida así sería
letal para la rentabilidad de cualquier
industria. No para los narcotraficantes,
especialmente los colombianos, para los que Europa
se está convirtiendo en su principal mercado. )
Una de las claves de este modus operandi es
que el principal beneficio en la industria
de la cocaína no está en la venta al
por menor ni en la producción, no,
está en el transporte. Según las estimaciones que
se manejan, el margen del productor de cocaína
puede ser de un 150% del coste de producción. El
margen de beneficio de la venta al consumidor es
de un 300%. Pero, amigos, amigas, en el caso
del transporte desde su lugar de origen hasta
el mercado final este puede llegar al 1.500%
dependiendo al lugar de Europa que llegue.
Y más de uno se estará preguntando, ¿pero por qué
hablas de Europa y no de otros lugares? Pues bien,
fundamentalmente es una cuestión de
rentabilidad. El precio de la cocaína en
la calle es mayor en Europa que en Estados Unidos.
Pero esperad un momento, porque hay más motivos.
Kristian Vanderwaeren, director
general de las Aduanas de Bélgica,
nos explica a quién le interesa más que las
drogas fluyan hacia Europa en lugar de al
gigante norteamericano.
Así que la pregunta es:
¿quiénes están haciendo en este caso de
mexicanos? ¿Quiénes son los intermediarios?
Pues bien, parece que fundamentalmente
son mafias procedentes de los Balcanes,
parientes lejanos de los albaneses que
se cruzaron con Liam Neeson en Venganza.
Estas mafias han levantado un imperio valorado
en miles de millones de euros. Han entablado
contacto con los carteles de Latinoamérica y
han ampliado las rutas de envío hacia Europa,
lo que está disparando sus ganancias.
Los principales países donde se produce
cocaína para clientes europeos
son Colombia, Perú y Bolivia.
Pero ojo, porque el transporte es diferente.
Se están empezando a transportar narcóticos
desde lugares que no están tan manchados
por el narcotráfico. En el caso de la cocaína
encontrada en Bélgica, la droga está llegando
desde Ecuador. Sobre todo desde el puerto de
contenedores de Guayaquil. Os hemos hablado de
ello en Latampolitik, el boletín de América
Latina que recibís los miembros de Patreon.
Desde Ecuador, pero también desde Surinam.
La cuestión es que el tráfico de drogas en
Amberes no para de crecer y está atrayendo a
mafias de todo el mundo. El crimen organizado
está intentando hacerse con este mercado,
algo que está desatando una ola
de violencia sin precedentes. Y
la pregunta es. ¿Cómo está afectando
esto a la buena gente de Amberes?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (SKYFALL)
En 2021, las autoridades belgas incautaron 90
toneladas de cocaína en el Puerto de Amberes,
prácticamente el 40% de toda la cocaína incautada
en la Unión Europea. Para 2022 los números,
se espera, que hayan sido muy similares y
es posible incluso que se haya cumplido la
previsión de las autoridades belgas de alcanzar
las 100 toneladas incautadas durante ese año. Los
narcotraficantes están usando Amberes como
su vía de entrada a Europa y las cifras se
superan año tras año, tal y como reconoce
Florence Angelici, de la aduana belga.
Estos continuos récords han supuesto
un cambio notable en el tráfico de
drogas hacia el continente europeo.
Tradicionalmente la cocaína viajaba
principalmente desde Colombia y
eran las costas del sur de Europa
las que recibían los cargamentos. Sin
embargo, eso ha cambiado. Hay dos países
del norte que acaban de superar a España como
los preferidos por los Pablo Escobar del momento.
(Bélgica y Países Bajos son ahora los principales
hubs de la cocaína en Europa, según Europol)
Ahora bien, que en Bélgica hayan
aumentado las incautaciones de
cocaína no es algo caído del
cielo. Es el resultado de dos
años de investigación policial culminados
por la conocida como Operación Sky ECC.
Sky ECC es el nombre de una app canadiense que
ofrece un servicio de mensajería
cifrada. Por si no lo sabíais,
encriptar las comunicaciones es el primer
tema del manual del delincuente profesional.
Así que según parece Sky ECC estaba
en el top descargas para los capos de
la cocaína. Por eso los cuerpos policiales
de varios países se marcaron como objetivo
descifrar esta app. La investigación
tuvo éxito e interceptó mil millones
de mensajes. Un año después de la Operación
Sky ECC, los resultados son espectaculares.
(Operación Sky ECC: 888 sospechosos y 4.500
millones de euros en drogas incautadas)
La caída de Sky ECC sacó a la luz
una gran red de empresas legítimas
creadas expresamente para importar drogas de
Sudamérica y lavar los beneficios cosechados.
También reveló una verdad amarga,
que es que los capos no se esconden
en las grandes mansiones de Bruselas
sino en villas lujosas de lugares tan
exóticos y lejanos como Dubai. Así que
es mucho más difícil echarles el guante.
Sea como sea, 4.500 millones de euros no
son calderilla y las mafias no se quedaron
de brazos cruzados. Respondieron como
se espera de los malos de la película:
con una venganza violenta que pone
a todos los belgas bajo amenaza.
Quieren causar temor y han llegado
incluso a intentar el secuestro
de Vincent Van Quickenborne,
actual ministro de Justicia,
después de anunciar un plan de lucha
contra el narcotráfico en Amberes.
El propio Van Quickenborne no
tiene ninguna duda sobre lo que
está pasando en Bélgica y lo resume
todo en una palabra: narcoterrorismo.
Y es que lo cierto es que Bélgica sufrió
en 2022 el peor verano que se recuerda en
cuanto a violencia se refiere. Bruselas
y Amberes han protagonizado continuos
titulares en los que se sucedían los
tiroteos, incendios intencionados,
apuñalamientos e incluso ataques con granadas
a viviendas y comercios. Hay una batalla por
el territorio y por controlar el epicentro
de la cocaína en Europa. Porque lo cierto
es que una verdad incómoda prevalece a pesar
del éxito de la Operación Sky ECC. Fijaos.
(El mercado de la cocaína, aún siendo
ilegal, no escapa de la ley de la
oferta y la demanda. A pesar de todas las
toneladas incautadas por las autoridades,
el precio en la calle de la cocaína no ha
aumentado y se mantiene estable en torno
a los 50 euros por gramo. Toda una señal
de que la droga sigue entrando en Europa
con suma facilidad. Es decir, hablamos
de un mercado enormemente lucrativo)
Las autoridades arrestaron a unas 160 personas
en el puerto de Amberes en 2021. Aún así es una
ciudad en la que ya es tan fácil obtener polvos
blancos como pedirte una pizza a domicilio. De
todos modos posiblemente todavía sea muy pronto
para hablar de Bélgica como un narcoestado.
Pero que nadie dude de que en 10 años
podría convertirse en uno si no logran
atajar la tendencia actual. Así
que la pregunta, por tanto, es:
¿Qué piensan hacer las autoridades belgas
para frenar el narcotráfico? Y ojo,
porque todo este tema tiene una lectura política
tan inesperada como sorprendente. Atentos.
T3 (EL FLAMENCO CONTRA VIVALDI)
Amberes es la ciudad más poblada de Flandes,
región que alberga un nacionalismo poderoso
encabezado por la Nueva Alianza Flamenca. Este
partido ha sido el más votado en las 3 últimas
elecciones federales belgas pero únicamente
formó parte del Gobierno federal durante una
legislatura y ni siquiera lo lideró. Lo más
habitual es que forme parte de la oposición
y su líder es [Bagt de vívej] Bart De Wever,
alcalde de Amberes durante los últimos 10 años.
[De vívej] De Wever es la figura política más
destacada del nacionalismo flamenco y ahora
está aprovechando el estallido violento
vinculado al narcotráfico en Amberes
para arremeter contra el Gobierno federal
belga, el formado por la coalición Vivaldi.
(Vivaldi es el apodo dado en Bélgica a
la coalición del gobierno federal que
desde 2020 reúne a representantes de 4 familias
políticas diferentes. El apodo hace referencia a
las Cuatro Estaciones del compositor italiano
Antonio Vivaldi, considerando que el verde de
los ecologistas encarna la primavera,
el rojo de los socialistas el verano,
el naranja de los democristianos flamencos el
otoño y el azul de los liberales el invierno.)
Por supuesto, los críticos de
De Wever consideran oportunista
utilizar el tráfico de drogas para
hacer política. Dicho de otra forma,
ven poco elegante intentar sacar
tajada de un tema tan delicado.
Claro que eso corresponde ya a la interpretación
de cada uno. Lo que no es menos cierto es que
hace años que el alcalde de Amberes declaró
la guerra contra las drogas y es de los pocos
representantes públicos que se atreven a hablar
de este asunto sin pelos en la lengua. Mirad:
(De Wever afirma que la gente no quiere ver que su
raya de coca está vinculada al crimen organizado)
El alcalde de Amberes ha llegado a denunciar
que el Gobierno Federal no está haciendo lo
suficiente para combatir los delitos
relacionados con las drogas porque la
élite social consume drogas. También hizo un
llamamiento a la reflexión de la sociedad al
considerar que se ha normalizado su consumo
y reivindicó del Gobierno más recursos para
reforzar la seguridad en el puerto de
Amberes y más competencias para que las
ciudades y municipios puedan enfrentarse
a la violencia desatada por los narcos.
El caso es que De Wever se ha convertido en
el paladín contra el imperio de los narcos.
Y ojo porque justo ahora eso puede tener
implicaciones importantes. Por ejemplo,
en las últimas elecciones federales, la
Nueva Alianza Flamenca se vio lastrada por
la gran subida de un partido independentista
radical de extrema derecha, el Vlaams Belang,
que fue aislado de la política de pactos
por tener un pasado en el que llegó a ser
ilegalizado por racista.. Pues bien, ahora De
Wever quiere evitar que continúe ese ascenso en
las próximas elecciones… Y aquí su campaña
antinarcos le puede venir que ni pintado.
(“Confederalismo o nada”: Bart De Wever
advierte de cara a las elecciones de 2024)
De Wever quiere que el Estado belga
se convierta en una confederación de
Flandes y Valonia para poder regir la
región flamenca de forma completamente
autónoma. Y ese “nada” ya sabemos lo
que significa en la política belga.
Sin la Nueva Alianza Flamenca ni la ultraderecha
independentista de Vlaams Belang en la ecuación
para formar una coalición de Gobierno, tiene
toda la pinta de que Bélgica se puede enfrentar
a otra gran crisis política con un Gobierno
en funciones que se prolongue sine die en
el tiempo debido a la falta de acuerdo para
formar un gabinete nuevo tras las elecciones.
Sea como sea, queda tiempo para
eso y de momento Amberes tiene
problemas más acuciantes. Problemas como este:
(La aduana incauta tanta cocaína en Bélgica que
las incineradoras ya no pueden seguir el ritmo)
Parece mentira pero las incineradoras
de Bélgica se ven incapaces de acabar
con lo que el fiscal de Amberes ha
bautizado como “la montaña de cocaína”.
Ni las incineradoras tienen capacidad
para quemar tanta cocaína ni lo permiten
las restricciones ambientales para
la destrucción de grandes cantidades
de drogas. Todo esto genera preocupaciones de
seguridad ya que se teme que las organizaciones
criminales puedan ahora atacar esos
lugares para recuperar algunas de las
toneladas incautadas. La buena noticia es
que parece que Vivaldi está reaccionando.
En primer lugar, porque el Gobierno federal
se ha movido para incrementar la capacidad
para incinerar drogas. Y fundamentalmente
porque ha prometido recursos para luchar
contra el narcotráfico.
(16 de septiembre de 2022:
El Gobierno belga revela un plan
para combatir el crimen organizado)
El Vivaldi ha prometido 300 millones de euros
para un plan llamado XXL. Se invertirán en
incorporar más de 100 agentes de aduanas al
Puerto de Amberes y añadir 5 escáneres fijos
más cerca de las terminales del puerto para
que al menos se puedan inspeccionar todos los
cargamentos sospechosos. Vivaldi también
ha atendido las peticiones del alcalde de
Amberes y a partir de ahora los municipios
estarán autorizados a ordenar el cierre
de negocios sospechosos de tener vínculos con
las mafias de la droga. Hablamos de pizzerías,
cafeterías, o peluquerías que están
siempre vacíos pero que nunca cierran
porque simple y llanamente sirven para
lavar una parte del dinero de los narcos.
Seguro que vosotros no vivís en Amberes
y también conocéis algún “negocio” así.
Sea como sea la pregunta ahora es para ti:
¿Crees que estas medidas serán suficientes
para frenar el narcotráfico en Amberes? ¿O
pensáis que las mafias van siempre un paso
por delante de la policía? Podéis dejarnos
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte a
VisualPolitik si aun no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.